en 3 tout ça pour
ça je vous rappelle que le Président
nous avait convoqué un grand renfort de
teasing en nous expliquant que ce serait
le grand rendez-vous de la nation qu'il
allait prendre une initiative qui allait
unir les Français qu'a-t-on vu en fait
quelques mesures une grande défiance des
de la jeunesse et puis toujours la même
chose sur les chômeurs que l'on
stigmatise la préférence internationale
qui est parfaitement assumée enfin on a
rien vu qui soit de nature à fédérer le
pays à l'emmener sur une vision sur sur
l'écologie rien ou presque sur la
démocratie rien sur les inégalités
galopantes sur le mallogement et cetera
rien on était quand même assez fasciné
par la vacuité du propos on va revenir
sur tout ça en détail vous diriez comme
d'autres que c'était un
bavardage je ne veux pas reprendre une
expression qui vient de Marine Le Pen
mais la réalité c'est que en fait on a
été convoqué sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision un soir à de grandes écoutes
pour finalement une opération de
communication mais qui n'a rien permis
d'envisager un second souffle pour le
kquena quelques chose qui viendrait
finalement suppler l'absence de campagne
présidentielle du chef de l'État et qui
viendrait dire ce vers quoi il veut
emmener le pays N a dit je ne sais pas
d'où les gens viennent et je veux savoir
où ils vont enfin c'est plutô le Premier
ministre qui l'a dit aux question
d'actualité hier mais où va-t-il où
emmène-t-il le pays personne n'en sait
rien en fait ne croyons pas que nous
allons résoudre le problème éducatif
simplement avec l'uniforme une cérémonie
de remise des diplômes et ple
marseillaise franchement qui peut croire
que ça va remplacer les enseignants qui
manquent ça va permettre de d'assumer ce
que nous avons à assumer pour emmener
une génération à la
maturité